健康と心の関係というテーマにしています
すごい俗的なテーマかもしれません
で 皆様にとってはもしかすると大変大事なことではないかと思うかもしれませんだけど
正直に仏教の立場から言うと
しゃべってもいけない
あまりにも俗的なテーマなんです
で なぜかというと この人間は 1 秒ずつ 1 秒ずつ年取っていく
それは止まりません 年取る
その瞬間瞬間年取っていくことによって
我々の体の全細胞も老化してしまう
それでいろんな機能働きをどんどんうまく活動しなくなる
なって やがてそれはうまくシステムが動かなくなって
どこかで我々は確実に死んでしまう
その流れを止まることは誰にもできません
どんな人にも どんな力ある人にも
それは認めることは人間にとって大変幸せですと仏教でおっしゃっているんです
なぜそんな暗いことを認めて幸せになるんですかと
我々はどう頑張っても死んじゃうよと
どう頑張っても病気になるよと
まあ何というふうに暗いことを認めること
なぜ幸せですかね こういうことなんです
我々の心の中で我々戦っているんです
大宇宙の法則に逆らって戦っているんです
すべてのものに対して
我々ちっぽけなこの個人という
この人間が戦っているんです
年取るのは当たり前の法則なんですけど
年にはなりたくないんだと
病気になるのは当たり前なんですけど
病気にだけはなりたくないんだと
とにかくずっと若さで元気で生きていたいと
と心の中で希望があるんですね
その希望で我々は努力して生きているんですね
ですから 人間の生き方というのは
この自然法則に逆らうことになっているんです
人間の生きがいは どうしても勝てっこはないものに当たってみようという
あまりにもバカバカらしいことになっているんですね
それで我々は毎日失望感を味わう
毎日虚しいということを味わっちゃう
毎日我々の生き方は嫌になってくる
すごい精神的な苦しみが生まれてくる
落ち着きが出てこなくなる
それから余計な苦しみが生まれて
その苦しみの方がものすごく偉大なる苦しみなんです
この自然法則に逆らってみようという苦しみが
それで自然法則の立場から見ると
あんまりにもバカバカらしいことで
これどうにもならないことなんですね
我々は富士山を足で蹴っ飛ばしてやろうと思っても
あれ足で蹴っ飛ばして倒れるものですかね
それで富士山は堂々と立っていて
じゃあやってみなさいと
怪我するのはあんただけですと
で 戦々恐々ともしないんですね
あ 痛えとも言ってくれないんです
富士山は で 我々の働きはもっとバカバカらしいなんですね
富士山みたいなほんのちっちゃなものではなくて
全宇宙の法則に対して逆らってみようと
で それで自分たちが大変悔しくなるんですね
その精神的な悔しさ 毎日 1 秒
1 秒ずつ精神的に負ける味わいっていうのは大変苦しいことなんですね
ですから それだけやめれば
ものすごく大変幸福になるんです
それだけっていうのは
この自然法則に逆らって病気にはなりたくない
年は取りたくない 若さはずっと保ちたい
死にたくはないという
そんな弱くはなりたくないとか
そういうことを置いておけば
そんなものは自然の法則だと
何のこともないんだと
そんなことに泣いたっても
ただ疲れるだけで何も意味がないんだと
ほっとすると 巨大なこの精神的な落ち着き
安楽が生まれていく それで初めて生きることは幸福になるんですね
戦うことはないんだから
残念ながら 世の中の人間がその幸福は味わえないんですね
みんな味わう幸福っていうのは
例えば 10 年間ずっと頑張って頑張ってバリバリ仕事したところで
いくらか豊かになったと
あるいは家族はもう問題なく
もう結構大きくなって
それぞれ社会人になりましたと
それぐらいのことで幸福を味わったりはするんです
ああ 美味しいものを食べて
ああ 良かったと 幸福だと
そのために我々は長い間苦労しているんですね
平和な家庭を作って 安全な家庭を作って
家庭の繁栄ですか 尽くすためには
もう大変な苦労をしなくちゃいけないんです
そういう並ならぬ苦労をした結果
ほんの瞬間が良かったと感じるだけですね
我々現代 味わう幸福感というのは
例えばもう一つ言うと
お金を貯めて どうにか外国旅行をしていくと
1週間ですね それ で  1 年間ちょきちょきとお金貯めなくちゃいけないんですね
それで 1 年間苦労して
1 年間もう一生懸命仕事をして
まああっという間の楽しみで
それ終わっちゃうんです
で 我々いうのはその幸福感否定しているわけではなくて
まあそれも人間にとっては楽しみの一種であると
私には財産がありますと
いい家族がありますと
借金はしていないんだと
誰にも借りがないんだと
何も悪いことをしないで
もう立派な人間で生きていましたと
今までまあ恥ずかしいことを
いけないこと 怖くなること
悪いことは何もしていないんだと
そういうふうなことは人間にとっては幸福であると
それは仏教でも まあそれはその通りですと
でもそれより 無量な幸福を感じることはできるんです
それは何か大胆な感激ではなくて
ずっと落ち着いていられることなんですね
いつでも平安な心でいられることなんですね
苛立ちしない 感情的にならない
ならない もう空気のように流れている水のように
まあ水も音はしますけど
ですごく静かに心は保つことをできれば
それはもう大変な幸福なんです
それには値しない 他の何の幸福も
世界の全財産 自分のものになっても
ありとあらゆる問題はかかっている場合は
何の幸福もないんです
精神的に何も安らぎを味わえない場合は
どんな財産に恵まれたっても
何も意味がないんです
自分の家というものがなくても
どこかで機能したで あるいは駅のホームででも生活したっても
もう何も苦しみがない場合は
心の中で苛立ちは何もない場合は
すごく緊張してビクビクして生活すること何もなく
自然と一緒になって 空気のように生きていられるならば
その幸福感は最高の幸福なんです
そういうことで あの病気とかなんとかとかなりたくないと
どうしても勝てっこはない
自然法則に逆らうんではなくて
放っておきなさいと そんなものは
そんなものは真実であることはありのまま見ておきなさいと
そこに生きるものにとっては幸福がありますと
でお釈迦様は幸福論を喋っているんですね
そこで次のポイントなんですけど
我々は健康的になりたいというのは
病気になりたくないというのは決して目的ではありません
皆様もそうなんです 皆様はどうか分かりませんだけど
ごく普通の世の中の人々は健康的になりたい
病気にはなりたくないと思って努力するんだけど
それ自体も人生の目的ではないんです
もう一つあるんです あなた健康的になってどうするんですかと
病気治ってどうするんですかと
ですから 目的はまだ先にあるんですね
すごい健康的な体を作ってから
私はこれこれこれをしますと
病気何もない体作って
健やかな体を作って 私はこれこれこれしますと
私は長寿を獲得して こういうこういうことをやりたいと
やりたいことは先にまたあるんですね
ですから あくまでも人間のこの健康を願う心
病気になりたくないと
年取りたくないと若さでいたいという
この願う心も 結局他の目的のためであって
最終的な目的じゃないんです
準備だけなんですね 他のことに
だから準備だけ揃っても
我々は落ち着かないんです
道具揃っただけで楽しくなるわけじゃないんです
それを使って何かしなくちゃいけない
ですから 残念ながら人間は健康的になりたいと言うんだけど
それになっても幸福にはならないんですね
なぜならば 健康的になってからやることに次第で自分に充実感が生まれるんだから
そこでまたかわいそうなからくりがあって
我々の幸福感 充実感を先に行ってしまっちゃうんです
そこで考えてくださいと頼んだっても
例えば自分が長生きできれば
いろんなところで 日本のいろんな美しいところを見ながら歩いたい
歩いてみたいんだと そういう目的があるんだと
ですから あっちこっち歩くことを目的で
そのために健康な体が必要ですよと
そこで じゃあその人は何か何か神通力でもあって
何か奇跡でも起こして健康的な体になったとする
それでその人は旅に出る
じゃあ 旅に出ることによって
その人は素晴らしく 充実感
幸福感を感じるという確実性ありますか？この旅でいろんなひどい目に遭う可能性はないんじゃないんですか？あるいは自分が希望した通りの結果にならない可能性は
あるのではないでしょうか
あるいはどこからどこへ行こうかな
今日どこへ行こうかな
あっちも行ってもいいし
こっちも行ってもいいしとかね
そういう決断ができなくて悩んだりすることはないでしょうかね
ですから 結局心の苛立ち
不安 それから不満感 そういうのは終わりくはないんです
それも覚えてほしいんです
ただ 何かをしては人間を幸福にしてあげてもじゃなくて
健康的にしてあげても
結局同じ苦しみの世界に戻るんですね
ですから ただ単にバカみたく健康的になりたいと病気を治してほしいとか思うんではなくて
やっぱり幸福になりたいと
充実感を得たいと 落ち着いて生活をしたいんだと
心の中の苛立ちやら不満やら
ありとあらゆる葛藤やら嫉妬
悩み 怒り 競争心 そういうのはなくして
光り輝く美しい心を作りたいということをやっぱり考えた方が一番仏教的なものなんですね
じゃ もう一つちょっとした問題があるんです
人間がもし科学的な発展によってか
突然神様でも現れて何か奇跡を起こした結果か
どっちでもいいんだけど
本当に完璧な健康的な人間になりました
そうすると人間は年取らないんですね
この年取ることも病気の一つなんです
大体そういうふうな そういうふうなことを言ってるお医者さんもいるんです
本当の病気は年取ることで
年を取るといろいろ器官は故障するだけで
みんなこの器官故障したことは病気だと思って
腎臓 腎臓やらいろんなことをいじったりするんだけど
本当の病気というのは年を取ること
それでそういういろいろ現象が現れるんだと
そうすると病気を消えたということは
我々は年取らないで 時間の流れをストップしたことになるんです
そうすると じゃあ時間の流れをストップしたと想像してみてください
我々はどうなるんですか？その瞬間で我々は終わりなんですね
もう時間の流れがないんだから
いわゆる変化の流れがないんだから
もう体は変化しないんだから
止まるんだから すべてが
すべてが止まったら そのすべてがそこで消えちゃうんですね
動くんだから 変化するんだから
この体があるんですね
この地球もあるんですね
その宇宙もあるんですね
ですから 頭の悪い神様でも現れてきて
奇跡を起こして もしその時間の流れ
現象の変化する流れを止まっちゃったら
すべての存在はそこで終わりと
じゃあ それを希望している人がいるんですかね
結局せっかく健康的になったんだけど
その瞬間から自分が生きていないんだと
自分がいないんだというと
なんかどこかで納得いかないところもないんですかね
ということは 健康とかね
年取らないということはあり得ない話なんです
全ての存在を止まることになるんだから
でも そのことは仏教では約束しているんです
我々はこの流れを止まることができるんだと
この法則の流れですか
この物質の消滅 変化していく流れ
心がずっと変化している
この流れを この変化させるエネルギーを止まってもらえば止まるんだと
例えば この地球がなんで自転して公転していますかというと
何かエネルギーのカラクリがあるんですね
そのエネルギーさえ 消してしまえば
消滅させればもう公転も自転もなくなっちゃうんですね
で 我々の体の中でもいろいろエネルギーがあって
次に次に次にと変えていかなくちゃいけないんですね
それはエネルギーの流れなんですね
だからいつでも我々はちょっと余分なポテンシャルというエネルギーを持ってるんですね
その余分なエネルギーで次の瞬間は作るんです
いつでも体にエネルギーを持ってるでしょうに
細胞はいつでもエネルギーを持って動いている
細胞の中にあるミトコンドリアというものは
いつでも酸素と組み合わせていろいろエネルギーを作り出してくれる
そのエネルギーで我々は活動している
だから エネルギーを作るためにもエネルギーが必要なんですね
そこで細胞の中でもエネルギーがあって
それで新しいエネルギーも作る
そこで我々は生きている
心のことを見てください
体のことはもう分かりきっていることだから
私は専門家ではないんだから
物質の世界の それは世の中の知識ですから
じゃあ心のことを見てください
いつも心の中で何かエネルギーを持ってるでしょう
そこで何か考えなくちゃいけない
何かしなくちゃいけないと
いつでも心の中にあるんですね
例えば 何もやることないとすごく落ち込んじゃうんですね
その時は何とかして心に刺激を与えるんです
テレビを見るか ラジオを聞くか
散歩にでもするか 家にいる人と喧嘩でもするか
何とかするんです 何とかしないでいられない心のエネルギーがあるんですね
例えば 皆様が誰かとちょっと意見が合わなかったならば
相手が言ったことは自分の気に障ったならば
そのエネルギーでスーッと心が回転し始めちゃうんですね
なんであの子とそんなこと言ったんですか？と思った瞬間
新しいエネルギーが生まれる
そこで次にそんなこと言うのは
あの人は失礼ではないかと
また次のエネルギーを作る
それで新しいエネルギーはまた次のことを考える
そういう風に 考え方から考え方へ
考え方から考え方へ スーッと切れることなく流れていくんですね
寝ても夢を見る 止まることないんですね
そこで仏教でいうのは
そのこのポテンシャルエネルギーですか
この余分に残る そのエネルギーをちょっと消滅しておけば
時空の流れがストップするんだと
そこであなたは消えますけど
あなたは永遠と言える究極と言える幸福を味わうんだと
また 2度と消えない幸福を味わうんだと
でもそれはもう残念ながら存在の次元とは関係ないんだから
人間にはそれを体験するしか
他の理解する方法はないんです
それは仏教で言っている涅槃という消えるということなんですね
涅槃の身っていうのは消えるということなんです
それ決して教務的なニヒリスティックなニヒリスティックなんです
今日これ教条主義的な考え方ではないんです
教条主義っていうのは
やっぱり実体論から成り立っている
くだらない考え方なんです
物事を知らないんだから
作っているもので で 例えがありまして
例えば あの ろうそくはいいんでしょうね
ろうそくは炎を立てて
つく火をつけて炎があるんだと
それでろうそくがずっと燃えているんですね
それでなんでろうそくは燃えていますか？燃え続けていますかというと
ろうそくは自分で燃えることによってエネルギーを作る
その作るエネルギーによって新しい蝋を溶かす
それでその蝋をまた燃やす
また燃やしたらまた炎が出てくる
それでずっと連続して
炎が生き続けているんですね
でも変化することで生き続けているんです
同じ炎がずっとあるわけじゃないんです
ほんの瞬間でも同じ炎がなくて
変えて変えて変えていくんです
新しい 新しいもの それで誰かがそのろうそくの炎に新しいエネルギーを入らないようにする
あるいは蝋が溶けないようにする
あるいは酸素がつけないようにする
そうするとどうなるんですか？炎が
炎は消える 炎は消えるんだけど
その炎自体が私ですから
瞬間瞬間生きている私ですから
その炎自体がどこへ行ったんですか？どうなったんですか？言葉で喋られますか？北へ行ったんですか？南行ったんですかと
上行ったんですか？下行ったんですか？あるいはろうそくの中に隠れたんですか
そういう言葉には当てはめない
ただ 原因なくなったんだから消えたと
そのように この心の中でずっと流れている
このすごいエネルギーを
ある限りは 我々は体を作って
ああ 死にたくない 死にたくないと言いながら死につついるんですね
病気になりたくないと言いながら
ずっと病気になって苦しんでいる
苦しみたくないと言いながら苦しんでいる
その炎のような そのものは消えるんだ
それは仏教でいう涅槃なんですね
それは本当に理解するためには
とことん人生の苦しみ
生きる苦しみ 生きる虚しさをとことん味わってみなくちゃいけない
まだまだ生きることに未練があるならば
まあしょうがないんですね
まあ悟りっこはない そういうことで
まあかなり人は修行はするんだけど
悟る人はもうまれになってるんですね
それはこの苦しみに何か未練があるんだからなんです
まあ話はまあなんとなく難しくなりましたけど
一応 いろいろからくりがあって
矛盾があるんだと 我々は希望している
この永遠か この究極的な健康っていうのは成り立たないと
成り立っちゃったら それはまあ全く違うものになるんだと
でもそれも仏教の教えから見れば可能なんです
それ 仏教の教えだけなんですね
残念ながら 別に宗教はいろいろ同じことを言っているかもしれませんだけど
他の宗教でどこかで存在することを喋っているんですね
何かになることを喋っているんですね
ですから それはなることであって
同時に変化することにもなるんですね
あるあるということだから
存在ということだから
ですから あの仏教だけですね
この何か永遠な状態になるとか
そういうこと ではなくて
煩悩を消すということ言葉を使っているんだ
とは そういうことで お釈迦様はこの真理は誰が発見したっても同じことですよと
修行は仏教であろうが誰であろうが
誰がやっても同じ結果が得られますよと
別にお釈迦様の特別な秘密の教えではないんだと
世の中のあることをおっしゃっているんだから
誰が発見したっても同じことを発見しますよと
と言いながらも でも人間が欲がありますから
なかなかそこら辺まで気がつかないんだと
ですから 今のうちは最終的な涅槃
解脱 悟りあるのはブッダの教えだけですと
ブッダが消えたところで
他の人をまた発見する可能性はあるのです
それはそれでいい  そういうことで
じゃあ一応これからもっと俗的なレベルに戻って
病気のことを大きなことを考えてみましょう
なぜ我々の体が この病気は 2つに分けて考えましょう
一つはどうしてもやむを得ない宇宙の法則による変化の流れ
どうしても赤ちゃんが子供になる
それはやめられません
子供がもう成長する 青年になる
若者になる 中年になる
その流れは止まりません
止まったところで 我々はそれは病気だと言うんでしょ
例えば子供が生まれて
もう 10年間ぐらいはそこそこと育ったんだけど
そこでいきなり成長はストップになったと
ご飯食べても どんな運動したっても全然成長しないんだと
そうすると 10歳のまんまでと
そうすると我々どう言いますか？それは病気だと言うんですね
あ それは病気だ この子は異常だ
なんか調べなくちゃいけないんだと
もって ありとあらゆる体を検査して
どんなホルモンがもう欠く欠けているんですか？どんな DNA の方がおかしくなっているんですか？とか
どんなものがこの成長を抑えているんですか？とも一生懸命探したりする
ですから それははっきり理解してほしい
自然の流れで我々は変化していくことは病気ではありません
でも一般の人々はそれも病気だと思うんですね
例えば 60歳になったところで
まあ前みたいに早く体が動かないんだ
ああ 悲しいですね もっとスポーツでも何か運動方法やら鍼治療法なんかないんですか？とか
なんとか探し求めているんですね
それも病気だと思うのはすごくおかしいんです
この自然の流れで変化していくこと
で 若い時はすごく食欲があって
よく食べられたんだと
年取ってくるとあまり味もわからなくなるし
そんなに食べたくはなくなっちゃう
ああ なんとか薬でもないんですか？とかね
まあ食欲を増やしてくれる薬でもないんですか？とか
何か自分の体を調べてもらって
もっと味を味わうような何か工夫はないんですか？とか思ったりすることはおかしいと私は思っているんですね
ですから 我々は病気を一応 2つに分ける
今説明したのは  1番目の病気の中
いわゆる自然の変化の流れ
それで年取って弱くなって死ぬ
それは病気だと思わないでください
髪の毛は白くなるかもしれませんし
膝が硬くなって曲がらなくなるかもしれませんし
いろいろ自然的になっていることは
そんなことは病気でないと
それを思うだけでも かなり我々はかなり幸福になるんです
2番目の病気は その流れと違う
何か起こることなんですね
例えば まあ二十歳なのに
もう何て言いますか インスリンが出なくなりましたと
それ糖尿病になったと
それは病気なんですね
65歳になったところで
あるいは 70歳になったところで
何かインスリンが出にくくなったというのは
それは別に病気ではないんです
どうせそんなもう古くなってるんだから
器官は で 二十歳になって二十歳なのにもうインスリンが出ないというならば
それは病気なんですね
例えば僕にもちょっとありますけど
この関節ですか まあ痛くなったりとか
それどんどんそちら辺はこの
なんて言いますか 硬くなったりするんですね
それ 今の年になって まあ少々あっちこっち硬くなったっても
痛くなったっても そんなことは別に大したことはない
でもその病気 この関節を硬くなること
若い時も現れますね 代であれは病気なんですね
で 我々の肺にしたっても
大体死ぬまで頑張れるぐらい力があるんです
肺は自分で自分を守ることは知ってるんです
そこそれなのに 肺の中でがんが現れたんだと
何か肺炎を起こしたり
いろいろ異常が出てきて使わなくなったとなれば
それは病気なんです ですから
本当はお医者さんはこの手加減というのは
この 2番目の病気なんですね
それで我々もその 2番目の病気
いわゆる自然の流れと違って
ちょっと異常現象が起こったならば
それを何とかすることはできるんじゃないかなと
それは何とかすることはできるんです
ですから 病気というのは 2種類がありまして
1番目はまあ放っておくしか方法なし
2番目は何とかすることはできますね
いわゆるごく自然的な病気ではなくて
特別なことになりましたと
まあよく皆様わかっているようないろいろ
バイラルインフェクションという
何でしたっけ？ウイルスに侵されることやら
いろんな細菌に侵されることやら
いろんな事故を起こすことやら
人間にはありますね それであまりも酒を飲みすぎて体が壊してしまっちゃう
脳はイカれてしまっちゃうとか
そういうのは あの まあ 2番目の病気なんですね
2番目のランクに入る病気なんですね
そういうのは止まることはできるんです
手遅れにならないうちに
手遅れになっちゃったらどうしようもない
日本ではものすごく酒を褒めてますけど
それはすごく脳細胞を犯すということは
日本のお医者さん一人も言わないんです
それは文化として褒めるのはいいんだけど
やっぱりそれも知ってほしいんです
飲むのは そのその方々は
まあそれ自分の希望で飲むのは
それはそれで自由ですが
やっぱりそれはやりすぎになると脳細胞を侵しますと
そうするともう取り返しはきかないんだと
もう治りくはないんだと
このアル中というのは脳の病気なんですね
早いうちではもうなんとか治りますけど
ちょっと過ぎちゃったらもう治れないんです
脳の中にこの穴が4つあるんですね
あれ 脳細胞早く死んで
その穴がすごく大きくなっちゃうんです
大きくなったところで
この液体 なんとか名前の液体がそれすごく中に入っちゃって
あの圧力がかけちゃうんですね
脳に そこで体がいろいろ現象を起こしちゃうし
とにかくその圧力を抑えるためにまた酒を飲まなくちゃいけないんです
そうなっちゃったらもう治らない
死ぬ 早く死ぬんです 皆さんはすごく手切りを見て
いろいろそれなりに大変美味しい食べ物を食べているんだから問題ないんだけど
そういう食べ物もない
あまり栄養ある食べ物ない国々ではみんな酒飲んでかなり死ぬんです
ですから 日本でそういう現象がないんだから
みんなその怖さが知らないだけ
私は毎日のように見ていることなんです
食べ物もない その代わりにお金ちょっとあったらすぐ行って酒飲んじゃうんです
1 日食べてないかもしれません
それであの毒をもう消すことはなかなかできなくて
大変残酷な状態 大体もう 30歳ぐらいの人々の葬式には結構行った覚えがあるんです
で 救済 救世ですか？ アルコール症ですか
その言葉 日本ではよくあるんですからね
毒なんですね  それは置いておいて
言いたがっているのは
そういうふうに我々の我々
なんか余計なことをしたりして
体を病気にする それぐらいは治そうとするならば治せるんですね
じゃあこれから この 2番目の病気を治すことに話を進めたいと思います
その前に この 1番目のランクに書いた病気についても一つ言わなくちゃいけない
この我々は この 1番目のランクに入るランクに入る
この自然的に病気になって弱くなって死ぬことも
病気だ 嫌だと思うのはやめてほしいんです
それもなんとかやめて
もう止まろうと思うと
余計に病気になって早く死んじゃうんです
余計に苦しむだけなんです
ですから 自然的な弱さには余計に薬飲んだり
余計ないろんなことをやったりしてはいけない
適当にほどほどに抑えてもらった方がいいんです
あんまりこの完璧になりたいと思ってはいけないんです
そうするとすごい苦しみなんですね
こう自然に年取ることは放っておきましょう
それで放っておいて それからも幸福になる秘訣があるんです
この自分が毎日変化していくことを楽しめばいいんです
毎日自分の心も体も変化していく
毎日周りも変化していく
それ楽しめばかなり素晴らしく
年取ることはもうしょうがなく
楽しくてしょうがなくなるんです
だからそれを得てください
1番目のランクの病気に対して
それはどういうことかというと
やっぱり毎日自分が変わるんだから
昨日の自分で今日も生きて生きていきたいというのはバカバカらしいんですね
じゃあ極端的に考えましょう
皆様方は 16歳の時はすごい美しい女性でいたことはもう明確に確かなんですね
その時はニコニコ笑ったり
遊んだり みんなにあー可愛い可愛いと言われてもらったりとかね
で 誰でももう行って一言を喋ってくれるわ
もういろいろありました
覚えが誰にでもあると思います
その今になって すぐ 16歳の時
自分の生き方を思い出して
同じように生きてみてください
1 日でも 自分が 16歳だと思って
服も 16歳の服に入れ替えて
アクセサリーもその 今の 16歳の子供たちのアクセサリーでいいんですからね
そういうアクセサリーもつけて
1 日でもやってみてください
どれほどおかしいか どれほど笑われるか
どれほど自分が残酷なことに遭うかということは
大体やらなくても想像できるでしょう
それは男の人に対しても同じことなんですね
ものすごい気持ち悪い人がテレビに出るんですね
あの男性に 日本ではすごい有名みたいんだけど
僕はもう彼が書いた本を 1つも読んでないんだから
僕にはもうバカにしか見えないんですけど
やること自体は書いてるものは別に頭は別ですからね
で ですから そのこの これ
僕 今極論言ったんですね
その極論で何を言おうかというと
この過去に戻ることはバカバカらしくて
すごい残酷で大変苦しみなんです
なんで子供たちは生き生きしているんですかね
なんで若者はえらい元気で可愛くてもういくらうるさくたっても心
大人の心の本心では楽しがってるんですね
うるさくてしょうがないんだけど
でもやっぱり心の中で
あいつらは可愛いんだと
あのうるささがなくなっちゃったら
なんとなく寂しいんですね
電車に乗ったっても 大勢でものすごいうるさくてむちゃくちゃなんですね
まあ嫌だなと思いつつも
結局降りて帰っちゃったら
なんかずっと電車がなんか寂しくなっちゃうんですね
えらい元気なんですね
小さな子供でも あれなんですかね
あれは子供たちは過去に生きていないんですね
子供たちは次に何やろうか
次に何やろうかと この変化を楽しんでるんですね
子供たちだけ現在と現在に生きていて
未来を目指しているんです
だからエネルギーいっぱい
すごく可愛い 愛称がある
誰でも大事にする で 私たちはいつかそれ死んじゃうでしょ
そのエネルギー あの笑顔
あの生き生きした姿 いつ死んだんですか？それは皆様のことだから思い出してみてください
あの子供の時あったあの明るさが消えちゃったんだからね
この消えたのは何月 何年
何月何日ですかね で 私たちはなんかわからないんだけど
徐々に 忘れちゃうんですね
今と先へ 今 今生きることと先を見ること
そのそれを忘れかけてくる
これは 1 日で起こるものではなくて
徐々に起こることなんですね
我々は徐々に徐々に暗く暗くなっていくんです
大体年齢で言えば この高校生ぐらいから始まるんですね
その老化現象 この不幸のこと
いきなり消えませんだけど
まあ大学生も結構明るくやってますけど
それで社会人になっても結構明るく若いとかやってますけど
やっぱりまあ高校生ぐらいになってくると
もうその明るさが明るさが消え始めるんです
そこで私の提案は この子供と同じく
今しっかり生きること
今 自分の年にふさわしい生き方をして
この変化を楽しむこと
いわゆる生き方として
子供たちの若者の生き方はと同じ生き方でいいんです
その生き方 生きる なんて言いますか
これ それこそ深いところのことですからね
別に子供やることやるんではないんだから
ですから もっと違う言葉で言うなれば
年取ることを楽しめばいいんです
毎日ものは変化する 今
今はもう二度とは戻ってこない
今の皆様方はもう二度と同じ環境で会うことはない
例えば私の年は今日はまあ何年何月何日かとありますでしょ
年はその年は明日になるともうないんですね
もう 1日年取っているんですね
ですから 今日は今日しかない
明日は違う明日があるんですね
その今日は思い存分生きていて
明日に準備をしておく
そうすると 我々のこの明るくてエネルギーいっぱいで生きてる
このエネルギーは消えなくなっちゃうんです
遅いと思わないで 今からでも頑張れば
そのエネルギーは生まれてくるはずなんです
ですから この一流一番目の病気に対して
我々はどんな態度をとるかというと
その変化に逆らうんではなくて
年取ることに逆らうんではなくて
それを楽しむ いわゆる
まあ具体的なことを言いましょう
で 例えば自分の孫たちがいて
元気で遊んでいるんだと
そこで自分も孫たちと遊ばなくちゃいけないと
同じ年の感じで孫たちと遊んじゃったら
まあ骨は折れるわ 腰は全然できないんですね
相手にすることは結局疲れる
せっかく孫と遊んで 1週間疲れて寝たきりになったとか
そういうケースもないわけはないんですね
あのボール遊びでもして
ボールを捕まえしたところで
もう足が滑っちゃって骨が折れたとか
そういうケースは僕は知ってるんです
そこで結局孫がいて幸福だけど
とんでもない不幸をかかもう回ってきたことになっちゃうんですね
私は言うのは その時はこの人は自分の孫だ
自分がおばあであっておじいであると
おばあさんがおじいちゃんがその立場を守る
私はおばあさんだからという風にそれを楽しめばいいんです
余計なことをしないで
おばあさんは孫に孫に対してアプローチする
おじいさんも同じく孫だと思ってアプローチをする
そこで子供も相手仲間だと友達と誤解はしない
それはおじいちゃんだ
それはおばあちゃんだと
それでちゃんと丁寧に挨拶して
おばあちゃんのところに行って可愛がってもらったりして
遊びたい時は自分が一人で行って遊んだりして
何か自分食べたいものがあるならば
お母さんが作ってくれない場合は
おばあちゃんのところでおばあちゃん
なんとかあれ作ってくださいませんか？と言って頼んで作ってもらう
それでおばあちゃん おばあちゃんの立場だから
それは権利だから はい
わかりましたと それ作って食べさせてあげて
その幸福を味わう 骨は折れない
その場合は その代わりに
孫とおばあちゃんのおじいちゃんの関係も素晴らしい
正しい健康的な関係になってしまっちゃうんですね
今の現代の子どもは理解しませんとかね
今の若い子は何やってるんですか？って
そんな余計な説教する必要なくなっちゃうんです
よくあるでしょ？うるさくうるさく言うんですね
この未来人に あの この古い人々が
この過去の人間が 過去の経験で未来人に説教していても
何も役に立たない せいぜい母親さえ子供の時代と違うんだから
そんなに分かったもんじゃないんです
子供たち生きてる世界は
ですから 我々そこら辺で間違うんですね
そこで間違わないで この自分の年を楽しむ
自分のその年の権利を十分使う
使うとすごく幸福に生きていられることできます
例えばすごく年取って寝たきりになったと
それでも自分が寝たきりだから気持ちよくお世話してもらう
いちいち文句言わないで
あれやれこれやれと命令する立場じゃないんだから
寝たきりになっている人々はよく命令するんですね
あんたいけません そんなことやったらあだとか
一生懸命 もう夜も寝ないで頑張っている人々は
これで嫌になっちゃうでしょうに
で 人に命令しないで まあありがとうね
本当に大変ですねとか何とか言いながら
感謝しながら あのあなた
あんた 本当に私の面倒見てくれて私は幸福ですよとかね
そういう自分の立場を認めたらできるんです
こんな体になってかわいそう
あなた方はかわいそうだと
で 私は早く死ねば本当にいいですねとか言いながらすると
向こうはおばあちゃん何言ってるんですかって言って一生懸命面倒見てくれる
ですから 寝たきりになっても
死ぬ瞬間でもすごく明るく幸福で
生きていられるんです
例えば子供たちのも勉強したんですかとか
学校に行ったんですかとか
そういうのはまあ心配しなくてもいいんだけど
まあただ口先だけでも聞くのは大人の仕事なんですね
寝たきりになっているおばあちゃんにでもそれぐらいは聞けるんだから
孫たちがお見舞いに来たら
あんた方はね ちゃんと勉強しなさい
こっち見なくてもいいとか
頑張ってるんですか？とか
そういう時でも やっぱりその正しい関係が生まれる
自分の病気も何の苦しみもなくなっちゃう
楽しく 楽しく 幸福で 元気で
死ぬ瞬間までいられる
それはこの 1番目の この何でしたっけ
病気に対する いわゆるどうしてもやむを得ない自然の病気に対する仏教的な立場なんです
そういうふうにして その病気を
自然の病気さえ乗り越えて幸福を感じることはできるんです
病気を治ることではなくて
ただ乗り越えて 病気によって不幸にならないこと
余計な苦しみを味わわないで楽しくすることはできるわけです
いわゆる我々には この体は弱くなっても
小さい時があった あの
あのエネルギー あの明るさを消す必要はないんです
エネルギーだから ずっとそれはもう同じ
同じ強さでずっと続けているようにすることはできますので
まあ大体それは 1番目の病気に対する
アプローチなんですね
で それについて まああの
もうちょっと年取ってくれて
もうちょっとあと その時間から計算すると
あと 3分ありますので
で もうちょっと年取ると
もうちょっとやったやらなくちゃいけないこといっぱいあるんですね
この今までやった欲的な勉強やら知識やら
全部片っ端から捨てる
今まで勉強したこととかいろいろあるでしょうね
それで楽になる まあどうせ持っていけないんだから
で その代わりに この普通では仕事をしなくちゃいけない
金儲けに勉強しなくちゃいけない
食べなくちゃいけないんだから
年取ってきたら その問題はそんなに問題ではないんだから
やっぱり勉強のために勉強する
自分のために勉強するということをしなくちゃいけない
そんな難しいんだから
はっきり言いますけど
仏教を勉強してください
それもいろいろくだらない仏教じゃなくて
お釈迦様の直接の教えを勉強するした方がもう混乱なく物事は済むんです
他の勉強 宗教の勉強で悪くはないんだけど
どんな宗教の勉強でも
やっぱり心のことを言ってるんだから
その分は役に立ちますし
でもしっかりと科学的に
明確に 具体的に知りたければ
釈尊の直々の教えを勉強してみてください
それ勉強し始めたら どんどん脳細胞が活性化するんです
脳細胞が足らなくなっちゃうんです
脳細胞が元気ということは
人が元気ということなんです
悔しくなるかもしれません
もっと早く始めた方が良かったのではないかという
それぐらいいろんなことあるんですね
勉強すればするほどすごく刺激的でもあるし
ものすごく楽しいし 瞬時に明るくなって元気になるんです
僕でも例えばもういろいろ疲れて疲れて落ち込んでくるなぁ
と思ったら何もやる気がなくなる時はあるんですね
物質ですから その時はまあどうかちょっと本ちょっと開けて
お釈迦様が言った一言葉ぐらい
一行ぐらい読んでみるんですね
一行読んだだけでも 瞬間電気ショック受けたような感じで
いきなり元気になっちゃうんです
あれ すごい不思議といえば不思議なんです
いきなりもう活動し始めちゃうんです
その智慧の世界見えますから
真理の世界 なんだ こんなことくだらないゴミみたいな世界だことだって
すぐそこでもう元気になる
すごい立ち直りが早いんです
そういうことで 我々はやっぱり年取ってくると
そういう心の勉強をすることに励んだりして
明るく生きていればいいんですね
じゃあ それからあの 2番目の病気のことを
じゃあ  2番目の病気 いわゆるこの普通に医学的にも病気ということ
それも 2種類ありますね
精神的な病気と体の病気と
で 仏教の教えから我々はできればこの 2種類の病気もなんとか治してもらった方がいいんです
それ  2番目の病気は治ります
2種類に  2番目に言った
このある日突然病気になったということはね
いきなり何かどこか悪くなった
胃か胃痛になりましたとかね
がんになったとか もうどこか悪くなったとかね
血液 血圧がもう随分高血圧になったとかね
そういうのは治ります
でもそれが老化現象の一種だったら
もうしょうがない それは区別しないことじゃ
で あの仏教っていうのは
すごい神秘的な話に 経典学的にすごく反対ですから
あの まずこういうことを言ってるんですね
あの 人間にはやっぱりサッパーエボージン
というものは必要ですと
このサッパーっていうのは
体に良く合う ボージナっていうのは食べ物
自分の体のシステムによく合う食べ物を食べなさいと
その一行で 世の中にあるありとあらゆる健康の食べ物のことやら
もうたったそれだけでまとめているんです
マイクロバイオティックする食べるんですか？あるいはああだこうだいろいろありますね
食べ物に対しては菜食主義にするんですか？とか
あるいは有機栽培の食べ物を食べな食べるんですかとか
あるいは動物性のたんぱく質控えるか
まああるいはイワシいっぱい食べるかと
みんないろんな あの まあ健康的なホウレンソウの食べ方とかね
毎日のようにテレビでもやってますからね
切りがないんですね  そこに大体僕は僕は笑うところあるんですね
みんなすごいこの食べ物にすごいえらい神経質なんですね
この健康的な食べ物を食べようと思っている人々も
それによって病気になるんで
あんまりにも神経質になっちゃって
健康食品 まあ健康的な自然に近い食べ物を食べよう食べよう
そればっかり考えて えらい緊張神経質になって
余計なまた新しい病気作っちゃう
僕用の僕は言いたいのは
確かに体にはふさわしい食べ物はあげないと体の健康は保せません
だからといって それによってまたヒステリーになったら
また違う病気が病気になります
ですから そこら辺でも落ち着いて
まあ適当に体にいい食べ物を選んで食べると
で この言葉はだいたいこの瞑想する場合は大変
瞑想する前に準備として言っている一つの言葉なんですね
瞑想はうまくいって早く覚めるためには
やっぱりあの食べ物にも気をつけなさいと
何だかんだでむちゃむさぼって食っただけ食って瞑想したってもうまくいかない
やっぱり体の健康的なバランスは必要なんです
体の健康的な状態 最高なレベルになってくると
悟りの方もさっさと進んでいっちゃうんです
で 僕らはいろんな人を見ているんだけど
なかなか進めない人々の場合は
いろいろ原因がありますけど
一つ見える原因というのは体の体が悪いんですね
姿勢が悪い 体の構造が悪い
いろいろあるんです で
それですごく邪魔になって
本人はそれ別に頑張ってはいるんだけど
邪魔になってなかなか心の進み進んでしまいないんですね
例えば腰 腰やら背骨とかね
ちょっとまあ猫背というか
曲がってなんかいるんだと
そういう人々はじっと座っていると
まあ分座ると 当然あっちこっち痛みが出てくるんですね
出てくるんだから どうせ分以上は座れないんですね
それでせっかく分で心が落ち着いてくると
もう痛くても立たなくちゃいけないんですね
だからものにならなくなっちゃうんです
そういうこともあるんです
ですから このやっぱり体の体調がよくした整えた方が大変
瞑想にもいいんです それから
どんな人間にとっても
健康のためにはサッパーエボージョナというふさわしい食べ物を食べてくださいと
でお釈迦様がこの直々指導するときは
あのお坊さんたちに聞くんですね
あなたは今指導を受けてどこに行くんですか？と
行く場所を聞いて まあいいでしょうと決めたりするんです
あるいはいえ あんたそっちではなくて
あっち行ったらどうですかとか
場所を変えたりはするんですね
で それどういうことかというと
やっぱりお釈迦様本人にあんまり言わないんだけど
あの その行く場所によって
お坊さんたちが得られる食べ物は変わっちゃうんですね
托鉢で生活するんだから
ある特別な村で住んでいる
その人々は食べる特別な食べ物しか自分も食べ食べなくちゃいけない
その人の体にそれ合うか合わないかわからないんですね
もし体に合わなかったら
もう大変なことになるんですね
それをお釈迦様は考えて
やっぱりこの場所を変えたりあげたりするんですね
でもお釈迦様っていうのは
あなた方はこういうこういうふうな健康に
こういうこういう食べ物食べなさいとは言わないんです
なぜかというと そう言っちゃったら
人間っていうのはもうおかしいもんだから
もう何するかわからないんですね
それで一生懸命その食べ物を蓄えたりする可能性もあるし
信者さんにいろいろそんなこと言って
ああいうものを私の体に合うのはああいう食べ物だから作ってくれという可能性もあるし
あるいは食べ物の勉強したり
研究したりして まあそういう栄養士になる恐れもあるし
そんなくだらないことをやるんだから
そこら辺はもうちゃんと押さえておいて
あまり言ってないんです
言ってないんだけど このいろいろ病気になったところでお釈迦様が薬を教えたところはあるんです
お坊さんとか病気になったところで
あの 適当な薬は あんたこういうこういうことをしなさい
こういうことを飲みなさいと
そういうことで 仏教はいつでもお祈りすれば病気治りますよと
神様にお願いすれば病気治りますよと
円納めたら病気は半分治りますけど
万円納めたらもう完璧に治ります
そんなことは仏教では言わないんです
まず いい食べ物を選んで食べなさいと
すごい科学的なんです
あの 2番目もありまして
あまり変わりようは書きたくないんだけど
つまりはい 音っていうのは
この水栓式という意味なんです
いわゆる環境なんですね
パリハラっていうのは使うという意味の言葉で
いわゆる自分の体に合う環境
それも考えてほしい たとえ今へんてこりんなことを言いますけど
この地球にしたっても
地球の磁場の働きも場所によって違うでしょうに
北極はすごい強烈であるし
南極は同じ強烈ですけど
また違う方向でエネルギーが働いているし
赤道の方はまた違うし
上に行けばまた違うし
南へ行けばまた違うし
我々も磁石で歩く磁石だから
この歩く磁石が大きな磁石の上で歩いてるんだから
だから地球に引っ張られて全然抜けないでしょ
磁石ですから そこでいる場所によって体の磁石の磁場も変わるんですね
ですから 自分の体の状態に合うところがあるはずなんです
たとえ日本で生まれたんだからといって
日本の環境はぴったし体に合いますよという人もいませんし
他の場所を体にということもあるんですね
ですから そこら辺もあんまり追っかけて行ったってもわからないんですね
で まあ私はちょっと一つ確かめたことがありますけど
この日本で大変 この磁石を使うんですね
健康にいいんだと あの血圧もすごく整えてくれるんだとかね
私は別にそんなことを一度もやったことがないんだけど
あのサンダル買おうと思ったところで
まあすごい安いサンダルがあって買ったんですね
まあできるだけ 1,000円以下のものを買おうとしているんだから
980円のサンダルってあって
まあそこに磁石を 3個ぐらいつけてあったんです
初めから持ってる時は
ああ これは儲かったもんだと
磁石は体にいいんだからって
みんなすごい もう 2 3円で磁石をつけてるサンダルを履いたりしているんだから
まあこれ 1,000円以下でいいんじゃないかと思って買って
まずは一応つけてみたんですけど
まあ 2 3時間あれを着けていると
体の調子が良くなるところが目が痛くなるわ
すごい目の下で圧力は感じるわで
いろいろ症状が来るんですね
それで見るとかなり血圧が高くなって高くなっていくようで
すごい気持ち悪い ある日
この散歩に行ったところ
すっごく気持ち悪くなっちゃって
早く早くこの海の方に行って
サンダルを捨てちゃって
普通の砂の上でもう 30 分ぐらいもう歩いたり立ってたりしてたら
それでずっともうまた落ち着いたんですね
そういうことはやっぱり大切でしょうなと私は思ったんですね
日本では皆様ごく平気で使っていて
それで健康を守ってますけど
私の体の場合はそれは良くないみたい
何も使わない方がいいみたい
ですから そういうふうなことなんですね
別に私は磁石に文句言ってるわけじゃないんで
それであの健康的になってる方々はそれでいいんですけど
みんなに同じことが合うわけじゃないんです
私の場合は体調を整えたければ
裸足でこの土の上で歩けば
もう すごく健康的になるんですよ
ですから  1 年 1 回しかできないんです
日本ではもうなかなか歩けるところがなくて
土がなくて で  foreign 行ったらもうサンダルを何も履かない
まあそれは 1 ヶ月間ぐらいいるんだから
できるだけもう裸足でいるんで
結構すごく力が入ってくるんです
すごくもう器官が機能しだしたりして
ですから この  それは皆様もどうかわかりませんだけどね
それはそれで ですから
我々にとって やはり今言ったのはへんてこりんなことなんですね
そんなにも気にしなくていいんです
大体 例えば肺が弱い人とか
気管支が弱い人は寒いところに行ったらいけないし
その人は暖かいところに行った方がいいし
で それからいろんなアトピーとかなんとかなんとかあるんならば
それなりの場所を変えたりした方がいいし
場所によってもそういうのはできますから
で この砂漠なんかはものすごいきついんだけど
この喘息とかある人々は結構治るみたいです
行っちゃったら で 私は知ってる人はもう
エジプトとかそういうところであの大使として
大使館でね 仕事をしていた人で
で 奥さんの方がすっごいひどく
この喘息なんです もうちょっとしたことでも
食べ物はほとんどないほど
そこで僕は聞いたんですよ
あなたがそんなに弱い体で
どうやってこの 10 年間ぐらいあっちこっちきつい国々にいたんですかと
そこに住む前は何にもなかったんだと
日本に来てから毎日寝たきりような状態です
そういうことはやっぱり環境ですね
ですから そういうふうに自分にふさわしい環境を選ぶとか
まあ 3番目は言わなくたっても
まあ運動することなんですね
怠けないこと  4番目は常に明るい心
持つこと それで大体我々の病気などはまあ消えちゃうんです
だから僕らには仕事ないんですね
お経をあげたら病気治りますよとかね
なんか祝福したら病気治りましたっていう風に
大変損はしますけどね
まあとにかくお釈迦様は真実を言うのはお釈迦様の仕事だから
そういう真実を言ってるんです
まず我々はこの体に突然現れる病気を抑えて
死ぬまでごく普通な健康的で
ごく普通に年取って 普通に弱くなって明るく死にたければ
やっぱりこういうことをやらなくちゃいけない
例えば この体にふさわしい食べ物という場合は
ただ美味しいんだからといって
もう何だかんでももうむちゃくちゃ食べることはやめた方がいいんです
お腹いっぱい食べることをやめなさいと仏教ではちゃんと言ってるんです
半分ぐらいで食べなさいと
お腹満腹になるまで食べてはいけないと
で ご飯食べて水をなんか飲んでからも
もうちょっともう少々だったら食べられるなというところで食べをやめなさいと僕らには言ってるんです
だからお釈迦様は我々は出家したんだから
修行しろ 修行しろだけではなくて
もうすごい健康な体で
もうみんなに迷惑をかけないように明るくいる
そこを全てのところで考えて
いろんなことをおっしゃっているんです
それからこの廃人ですか
このなんていうんですか
はい 廃人 廃人 清潔みたいな言葉ですけど
廃人衛生 あ そうそう 衛生的な面で仏教はすごい厳しいんです
で 衛生が失ったら当然あの病気になりますから
そこでこのお坊さんたちっていうのは
もうみんな一緒に生活しているんだから
たくさんの人々が でも
お寺っていうのは結構衛生的で綺麗にしておかなくちゃいけない
衣でも髪も頭でも体でも
いちいちきめ細かくもう書いてるんです
でも 皆様にはそんなことは
一般の方々に向けて喋るっていうことはそれほどない
で それは自分勝手にやってもいい
からね 自分の家ぐらい自分で掃除すればいい
お釈迦様が言うまで待ってるっていうならば
もうとんでもないことだから
でも お釈迦様のところに入って住み込んだ人々には
それは厳しく また男性
ほとんどお釈迦様の側近の男性ばっかりだから
で どうせだらしないんだから
それでもお釈迦様は厳しく
厳しく 部屋の掃除 部屋の掃除のやり方
衣の洗い方 たたみ方 いちいちいちいちきめ細かく
で 病気になった人のどうやって看病するんですか？病気になった人はどうやって看病を受けますかと
そういうのは戒律として書いているんです
ということは お釈迦様から見れば
我々はこの衛生的な管理もきちんとしなくちゃいけない
そんなものは病気 だからわかりやすく言えば
病気になったら なんで私は病気になったでしょう
なんで私は不幸になったんでしょう
なんで私だけそんな目になったでしょうとかね
そんなことを言うんじゃなくて
しっかりしろと 初めからもうちゃんと食べ物を食べて
ちゃんと自分にふさわしい環境を選んで
適当な体を働かせて もう衛生を守って
それから明るい心でいれば
何にもないんだから 人間
自分の生き方が悪いんだから
あちこち突然病気になっちゃうし
それで神を恨んじゃうし
お釈迦様を恨んじゃうし
みんなに文句言っちゃうし
いい加減なんですね そういうことなんですね
結局 お釈迦様はそこら辺でおっしゃっているのは
あなたの過去のカルマが悪いんだから
あんたいつまでもそんな病気になってるんですよとか
そんなことは原始仏教では言ってないんです
新興宗教的な仏教では言ってるみたいだけどね
あなたにはこの何とか因縁が怨念ですか
なんとかありますよと
それはお祓いしなくちゃいけないんですよとかね
お釈迦様さえあれほど悟って
あれほど浄悩ればと お釈迦様さえそんなことを言ってないのに
えらい現代 こんな何もできない
もう勉強もしていない
世の中の知識も知らない連中が
よくも人々にそんなことを言って
新宗教まで作って膨大な金を集めてやってますからね
僕はその人々には怒りません
頭がいいんだから とにかく
とにかく金儲けやってるんだから
あれに言ってる人々に文句言ってるんですね
猿どもだと勉強したんだから
自分で物事を理解判断すればいいのに
ちゃんと学校に行ってるんだから
大学出てるんだから それは使わないんだから
言ったらすぐ信じる 頭おかしくなることをするし
まあそれはまあ話余計な話ですからやめますけど
で とにかくまあ衛生も衛生的なことも気にしなくちゃいけない
だいたいそこら辺 この食べ物
食べ物の場合は 仏教は酒には反対ですね
まあそれはしょうがないんです
で 食べ物 酒には反対ですけど
薬をあるんです アルコールでしか溶けない薬
アーユルヴェーダ薬の場合は
この成分というのは何でも水に溶けるわけじゃないんだから
油に溶ける成分があって
アルコールに溶けるものがあって
水に溶けるものといろいろありますから
その場合は 使っても構いませんと
その時は薬飲んでいるんであって
アルコール飲んでるわけじゃないんです
だからどうしようもないんですね
薬を体の中に入れなくちゃいけない
それはアルコールでしか溶けない
それからこの塗る薬あるんですね
いろいろ アーユルヴェーダでは
その塗る薬の場合も この塗った薬の成分が体の中に吸収するためにも
いくらかのアルコール成分が入れているんですね
ですから お坊さんたちには酒一滴も飲んではいけないんだとキツく言っていて
でも病気になったら もし薬にアルコール成分が入っていたならば
そちらにアルコールの働きはない
アルコールの代わりはしない
アルコールの味はしない
その場合は使ってもいいと
ということは梅酒は飲めないですね
酒だから僕は香り嗅いだことがないんだけど
そうそうで言ってますけど
例えば体にいいんですよと誰か私に梅酒を勧められても
もしかするとまだ嗅いだことはないんです
あれ アルコール入れて作るでしょ
じゃあ梅なんとかありますね
焼酎というんですけど
わかりません そういうのは飲んではいけない
アーユルヴェーダの薬は飲めるんです
アーユルヴェーダの薬の場合は
わざわざアルコール入れないんです
その代わりに蜂蜜か黒砂糖か入れて
あるいくらほんの少々入れて
もう 1ヶ月か 2ヶ月間とか置いとくんですね
この薬を置いといたら
ほんの少々発酵して ほんの 0.1以下のアルコール成分は溶けちゃう
それは飲んでもいい まあですから
このアルコールに反対のことを言っただけのことなんですけど
で 食べ物に対しても 何でも食べるんじゃなくて
美味しいんだから食べるんじゃないでなくて
お腹いっぱい食べるんではなくて
ただ体を維持する維持するために適当に食べて
いつでもお腹の状態を休めるようにする
そういうことで それから自分の体に合う食べ物を選んで食べたりとか
そういうふうなことで我々の健康的な体を保つことはできるわけですね
そこで それでも病気になる場合は
お釈迦様は何言うと思いますか？それ全部守っても病気になったと
お医者さんのところに行けって言うんです
お医者さんの仕事はきちんと認めているんです
例えば いくら食べ物を食べて
いくら明るい心でいても
どこかからインフルエンザウイルスが体に入り込んだりするのは
それはやむを得られませんだから
例えば 最近食中毒の件あったでしょ
そういうものはわかりませんだから
いくら気をつけたっても
もうついそういうものは体に入る可能性はあります
その時はもう神も仏もこの世の中でないんだとかね
恨んだりするのはもうバカバカらしくて
その時はちゃんとお医者さんに行って
その偽偽物を体から取り払い取り払ってもらった方がいいんです
そういうことで みんなに言うために
この神秘的になるな 迷信をするなということを言うために
お釈迦様は病気になったところで大体お医者さんに行ったんです
そんなに病気になったことはないんだけど
怪我したんですね だいぶだったというお坊さんに殺されかけて
そこでちょっとした怪我したんですね
で 怪我した時はお釈迦様の足の指ですか
親指を怪我して血が出て
で それを聞いて もう大変なことをしたんだとね
このジーワカという国の王様
王様のお医者さんでしたけどね
で 彼が走ってきて じゃあ私が治療しますと
言ったら 別にお釈迦様
まあこの怪我ぐらいはね
治療しなくても治りますけど
お釈迦様はまあはい お願いしますと
ちゃんと治療してもらったんです
それでまあ大体 1 日で
まあその傷跡はもう治りましたけどね
で 心は落ち着いていると
この傷のような この体のこの事故みたいにあっち傷が入ったとか
それよくあることなんですね
そういうのはすぐ治るんです
で 皆様を見て 例えば皆様
包丁にでも指なんか切っちゃったら
すぐこの血を吸ったり
バンドを張ったり まあ慌てるでしょ
それ何も慌てないで ほんのちょっとだけ血を出るようにして
それからすごく楽しい明るい気持ちで指で押さえてみてください
1 分間つなげるんです
何もなくても で バイキン入っちゃったらつなげますけど
中で化膿しますから それは危ない
ですから血をちょっと出した方がいいんです
血を取って出して なんのことなく明るい気持ちでちょっと押さえて
軽く押さえておけたらつなげていますよ
そんなことは奇跡ではないんです
ですから この傷とかそういうものはすぐ治るんです
大体せっかく仏教からどうやって病気治りますか？と聞いたところで
当たり前のことを言っているんではないかと
もうみんな諦めてるかもしれません
なんだ 当たり前のことを言ってるんではないかと
そこはいいところなんです
なぜかというと みんな宗教っていうのは誤解しているんです
へんとか 変なことを言うのは宗教だと
迷信的なものを言うのは宗教だと
あれはおかしいんです
すごい科学的なことを宗教を言わなくちゃいけないんです
科学者より科学的なことを言わなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで  たとえお祈りしたところで病気治ったならば
なんで病院があるんですか？例えばキリスト教の方々も病気治するんですよ
あのヒーラーという人々がいて
あの たまにいるんです
グループ作って世界中回るんです
私の国にも来るんです
このキリスト教の色々グループが
そこで大きなもう楽器いっぱい揃って
まあ歌うは踊るは 神様にもハレルヤを歌うは
いろんなことを歌って
もうひっしになって もう神様
この人をなんとか病気治してください
神様 この人をなんとかなしてくださいとか
ものすごい強烈な声で喚いたり
もううるさいうるさいんです
すごい もう拡声器はいっぱいかけてやってますから
そこで病気奇跡的に治りましたと
また例を出したりもするんですね
というならば キリスト教文化で人の病気が治るならば
なんでキリスト教の人々は世界中病院を作っているんですかね
今 我々の伝統的な体にいい治療法は全部死んじゃって
西洋的な治療しかないでしょうに
世界支配して 西洋的な医学はね
巨大な病院作って ちょっとした病気にでも何十万円もお金がかかるぐらいにして
お祈りすればもうタダで無料で治るのに
ですから そんなくだらないことを私はもうあまりおかしいと思いますね
やっぱり本心で知ってるんです
お祈りしただけでは治りくはないんだと知ってるんだから
みんな病院なんか作ってるんです
キリスト教のシスターたちが一生懸命看護婦をやってるんです
アフリカとかあちこち行ったら
みんな一生懸命病院でもう苦労しながら面倒見ているんですよ
もし神様にそんなに力があるならば
なんでこのヨーロッパのシスターたちがアフリカやらそういう厳しいところに行って
寝るところもないし もうシャワーをするところもないし
何もなくて えらい苦しいことをしながら
まあみんなに治療したり
面倒見たりしているんですか？お祈りしちゃえばいいんだから
みんなまとめて だから宗教の専門家さえそれを信じてないんです
信じてないのに口で言うんですね
お祈りすれば治りますよと
そんなものは明確な嘘なんです
ですから まあそこはまああんまりあんまり別に気にしない方がいいんです
やっぱり病気だったらお医者さんにお願いした方がいいんです
それはお医者さんの仕事であって
我々の仕事ではありません
お医者さんにご飯食べられないようにしちゃったら
それは宗教がやるべきことではないんです
で 例えば いくらそういうこの 4つの原則を守っても
病気になるとかありますからね
いくら明るい心でいたっても
車に跳ねられる可能性はありますから
ですから その時はお祈りするんじゃなくて
さっさと病院 病院に行ってお医者さんにお願いすればいいし
で それからな それから宗教に仕事があります
これがポイントはところであります
じゃあ 我々 心で落ち着いてないと
いら立っていると わがままで高慢でいると
自分を過剰判断していると
治る病気も治らないんです
例えばものすごくいら立ったりして
もう高慢で怒って もう人にさんざんあれ言わ
これ言うわ そういう人がもうその状態でいるときは頭が痛くなったと
それで痛み止めを飲んだと
飲んでも治らないんです
それを覚えておいてください
大体このいろいろ薬ありますでしょ
簡単にこの頭痛ぐらいは治る薬はどこでもあるし
バファリンとかね まあ名前言ったら宣伝していると思いかもしれませんだけど
他の名前知りません私は
まあただそれだけのことで
例えば頭が痛い時はバファリン飲んだと
飲んだらすぐまあ 15 分ぐらいでもう治るんです
痛みはわからなくなっちゃうんです
でも自分が苛立って 神経質で
もういろいろ混乱だらけでいると
もう治らないんです 治らない場合は
結局飲んだ薬の効き目もないし
薬は毒になっただけなんですね
そこら辺 我々の仕事はあるんです
バファリンをやめることではなくて
違うところで 例えば手術したっても早く治る人がいて
全然効き目がない人いるんですね
傷跡はすぐ消える人がいて
傷跡はもうなかなか治らない人もいるんです
そこら辺は何ですか？とお医者さんはわからない
お医者の仕事は一応手術して
もう治るか治るまで待ってることしかないんですね
あなたはなんとかなんとか病気ですから
なんとかなんとか薬を飲んでくださいと言って
薬を飲ませ 注射させて
まあいろいろ機械入れたり
いろんなことをして待ってるしかないんですね
自然に治るまで そのところで仏教から何か役に立つところはあるんです
すごく明確にしてください
どこの仏教にどこに仕事があるんですかと
どんな病気も 1 発で治ってやるということではないんです
他のことをやったところでも治らない時あります
それは心の問題なんです
ですから いつでも明るい心
謙虚な心も必要なんですね
いつでもいわゆるこのいかなる高慢でも良くないんです
どんな形の高慢であろうか
良くないんです それで自分がやられちゃう
そういうのはお釈迦様から言えば猛毒なんですね
人間の体にいろいろ猛毒があるんだと
その人間の体での猛毒っていうのは
嫉妬 怒り 瞋恚 高慢 そういうものなんです
苛立ち このすごくもう苦悩ですか
悩むこと 憂い そういうのは猛毒なんです
ですから いくらいい食べ物を食べても
心は汚い人の場合は食べ物は当たるんです
心が汚いんだから そこら辺は私たちには何か手助けすることはできるんです
例えば あのバファリン 20 飲んだら頭痛が消えますという人が
すごく落ち着いて明るくいるし
それでちょっとした体の構造上で問題があって
ちょっと頭が痛いんだと
その場合は 1錠飲んでも治るんです
薬は半分は控えるんです
たまに薬なくても病気
治るんです ですから 心さえ清らかにしておけば
で まあせいぜい 70%
90% 今我々苦しんでいる病気は消える
それは確かな事実なんです
それどういうことかというと
こういうことなんです
じゃあ それから理論を説明します
人間の体っていうのはただの物体ではありません
ただの物体というならば
普通のこの車みたいに
この時計みたいに ありとあらゆる機械と同じですから
そのただの物体の場合は普通のエネルギーの法則で動くんです
エネルギーを入れちゃえば動く
この冷房は電気入っちゃったら動く
それだけ なんかどこか故障したらそれ入れ替えればもう OK です
機械っていうのはそんなもんなんですね
体の場合はエネルギーは 2種類があるんです
一つは我々得られる食べ物
もう一つは心そのもの
心そのもので この体は生きているんです
すごいエネルギーなんです
で そこで強烈なのは心のエネルギーなんですね
体という機械は 2種類のエネルギーが必要です
一つは食べ物 物質的なエネルギー
もう一つは心というエネルギー
そこで心というエネルギーの方がすごい大きいんです
それはどういうことでしょうかというと
例えば私たちは死んだとする
死んだところで お医者さんが来て
体の体温を守って 体にじーっと機械で管を持って栄養を与えているんだと
スーッと それで体は植物としてスーッと続けますか？例えば人を死んでももう構いません
機械を入れていろんな栄養分を与えて酸素を与えて
この細胞を死なないように
いわゆる植物として生かしておくことはできますか？と
できない ある時間はできます
植物ですから やっぱりどんどん細胞は壊れて腐っていっちゃうんです
何かエネルギーは足らないんです
大体この細胞なんかは
今の医学では長い間保存するためには
何ですか 液体窒素 リクイド
窒素 液体窒素の中に入れておくんですね
そうするともう外へ出しちゃったらまた生き返りますけど
その場合は完全に物質をストップさせちゃうんですね
物質が動くことを 熱を取り出して
それだけで でも生かしておくことはできない
部屋の温度で いきなり死ぬんではなくて
いろいろ工夫すると物質としては生き続けますけど
いくらか でもどんどん壊れていくようになるんです
そのエネルギーは足らないエネルギーは心のエネルギーなんですね
私たちの場合は もう体はご飯をあげなくたっても
いきなり死ぬわけじゃないんですね
で 全然体が腐らない 結構死ぬまではきちんと細胞は生きてるんですね
そのエネルギーは心のエネルギーなんです
で その難しいことじゃないんです
例えば 私はこの小指を曲げたいんだと
小指を曲がる それは機械的な働きだと思ってるんですか？じゃない
私は小指を曲がりたいんだから曲がってるんです
ですから 心の命令があって曲がってるんです
機械的に曲がってるわけではないんです
私は喋りたいんだから喋ってるんであって
スピーカーみたいに ラジオみたいに機械的に喋ってるわけじゃないんです
ですから 我々の心臓を動くことも
肺が活動することも 細胞 1個 1個生きてる場合は
強烈に心とエネルギーで支えていて
生かされているんですね
それにその心の心という
そのエネルギーは汚れたらどうなるでしょうか
いろいろエネルギーは汚れたら
我々は毒を食べたらどうなるんですかね
何かお腹が空いたんだから何か食べなくちゃ
じゃあ毒でも食べてやろうと思ってやったら死ぬでしょう
同じく心も栄養であって
心は栄養です それも覚えておいてください
栄養 4種類あるんです
他の講演で他に僕は言ったことがありますけど
滋養素といって体を養う栄養は 4種類ありまして
1番目は物質的なエネルギーで
3 3種類が心のエネルギーなんです
ですから 仏教では心も一つの字を想を通して栄養として見ているのです
で あの そういうことで
この 心が汚れたら余計に病気になる
ならなくたってもいい病気になる
皆さんは知っている このあまりストレス溜まっちゃったら
体はガタガタ壊れるでしょうに
あれは余計なことなんですね
そんなにストレスたまらなくてもいいし
リラックスしてニコニコと生活すればいいし
仕事難しいんだったら
別にストレス溜まる必要ないんだから
ああ やれやれ 難しい仕事だな
これはやれっこはないなと楽しめばいいのに
まあとにかく頑張ってはみるんだけど
どう行くかわからないんだと
それぐらいリラックスしてやればいいのに
余計にもうストレス溜まって溜まって体壊しちゃう
それは自分が自分の心
体で毒作ってるんですね
ですから  3種類の栄養は心なんです
それは明らかにしてほしいんです
どうやって汚れるかと
一番汚れること わがままというか
高慢なんですね 自分が偉いんだと
自分がもう何々何々さんだと
自分の立場を持って考えているんですね
例えば会社で上司に叱られたら部下が腹が立つんですね
それは自分が偉いと思っているんだからなんですね
これ 高慢から生まれるんですね
上司の悪い なんでそんなこと言わなくたっていいんではないかと
私は入ったばっかりだから
そんなことわからないんではないかとか
そういう気持ちでざーっとこの胃の中で胃酸が出始めちゃうんですね
何のこともなく まあ言いたい放題言ってちょうだいと
聞いてあげます それ聞いていればいいんだから
別に みんな喧嘩するのも高慢だからなんですね
あんた何を？という感じで
私に向かってなんでそんなことを言うんですかと
それで腹が立っちゃうでしょう
それということで 高慢は一番病気のもとになっているんですね
高慢は怒りに繋げちゃうし
そこに怒りっていうのは
かすかな怒りも体に毒として残るんです
で 心が変わるたびに 体の中ですごい新しい物質が生まれる
で 心が変わるたびに いろんな新しいホルモンが出てきて
体の構成が変わっちゃうんです
ですから 大変気をつけた方がいいんです
例えば 若者は恋している時はもう世の中のこと何も見えない
その時はもう全く違う人間なんだよ
親言うことも 大人言うことは全く聞けないとか
あるいは失恋したところで
もうまた世の中見えなくなっちゃう
それなりに心が変わるたびに体が変わって
生き方が変わってしまっちゃう
それたびに心 体の健康も良くなったり悪くなったりはする
ですから 我々は自分勝手に心というものは毒に入れ替えて
同じ心なり ちょっと形が変わったら毒なんです
で 病気になってるんですね
そこでお医者さんが治療したっても
心が悪い人が病気治らない
すごく遅くなる ひどくなる
たとえインフルエンザじゃなくて風邪ウイルスでしたっても
落ち着きのない人には時間がかかる
明るく落ち着きも全然全く平気でいる人にとっては早く治る
体の T 細胞はきちんと出てきて
もうウイルスを抑えてくれる
ですから 精神状態はとても大事なんです
そこで食べ物の問題なんですけど
明るい人が別に何食べてもそんな問題がないんです
それは明るく楽しく適当に適量食べる人は別に体が太ったとかね
まあそういうこともないんです
そういうことで この明るい心を作った方が病気が治る一番方法なんです
じゃあどうやって明るい心を作りますかというと
皆様はいろいろ仏教のこと知ってるんだからわかりますけど
僕 普通の人に向かって喋る場合は
あんた嫉妬するな 怒るなと言ったっても
やっぱり怒る癖ある人は怒っちゃう
嫉妬する癖ある人は嫉妬しちゃうし
高慢の人はいくら言ったっても高慢で喧嘩はするし
言っただけでは治らないんですね
それで工夫して いつでも明るい心を作らなくちゃいけない
一番強烈な心清らかにする方法っていうのは
慈悲の心なんです あの頭混乱してくると
いつでももう全部もう忘れちゃって
生きとし生けるものは幸福でありますようにとか
呪文みたいに唱えた方がいいんです
頭狂う狂ったような感じです
生命は幸福であります
生きとし生けるものは幸福でありますようにとかね
そうやって頭狂ったような感じで
その呪文 呪文じゃなくて文句を唱えると
その言葉の力で言葉っていうのはきれいな言葉だから
どんどん汚くなった心がきれいになっていくんです
そういうことをできるようになったら
すぐ自分の怒りをコントロールすることができるんです
その働きを見て バカな人々がやっぱり呪文には力があるんだとか
これには神秘的な科学では証明できない
もう大変な宗教的な力があるんですよと
嘘です あんなもの 大槻教授のように説明できないものは何もないんです
で その文句を唱えると
当然のことで 自分の心の怒りの概念が消えちゃって
優しい心が生まれる ですから
仏教では病気を治す特効薬として慈悲の瞑想を使っているんです
それだけではなくて 自分が自分に慈悲のエネルギーが積めたら
人の病気も治してあげることができるんです
心はすごい影響し合うんですね
ですから すごい優しい心で
母の心で 仏様の心で もう何も見返り求めないで
人に何かしてあげたいという気持ちでいる人が見ただけでも
他の人々は明るくなってしまっちゃうんです
それで相手の病気を治してしまっちゃうんです
ですから 覚えておいてください
特効薬みたいにあるのは慈悲の瞑想
そのいろいろやり方があるんですね
慣れなくちゃいけない
で 瞬間でも慈悲の瞑想をすると
自分がその瞬間でも体に強烈な
この何と言うんですかね
あの なんかこの感動じゃなくて
言葉をすいません なんかこの中国の伝統では何か何か長寿寿命やってくる
何か特別な薬があるよというふうな神話的な話あるでしょ
なんか何とかという わからない
その瞬間でも 自分たちが慈悲の瞑想していたら
すごい強烈な万能薬みたいなものが体に入ったと思ってください
生命は幸福でいてほしいなと思った瞬間で
自分の体ですごいエネルギーが生まれちゃうんです
すべての病気を治す力が生まれる
それを何回 何回 何回言い続けて
自分が慈悲の心と一体になるように
慈悲しか自分の感情ないようにしてほしい
そうすると死ぬまで全然病気にならない
2番目の病気 そういうことで
例えば だからお釈迦様は一回しかお医者さんに会ったことがないんです
昔のお坊さんたちも病気になったらすぐ自分でそれを治してもらうんです
自分で治す 食べ物でもちょっと当たったら
ちょっと心を込めて そこをちょっと観察して
それでも治ります すごい力強い瞑想なんですね
それからこの皆様は慈悲の瞑想
システム的に知ってますけど
この知らない方々に皆さんもやってみてください
このみんなも歌を書くという歌は俳句とか書くでしょ
ですから こんなこのもう俳句も俳句いいんだけど
もう意味はね 何書くんですかね
あんなもうなんか花 季節の
なんかくだらないのではないんですかね
じゃあこれに句書きますよとかね
そんなことではなくて
愛の慈しみの俳句を書いてみてください
別にあの歌として良くないかもしれません
それは構いません 何か花
朝顔を見たら 何か朝顔を見て
何か季節の言葉も入れて
で 何か人の生命大事に考えたことが浮かんで書いてみてください
例えば朝顔を見て心が明るくなったと
と で みんなの心を明るくしてちょうだいと言ったら
そのような意味のことを言ったら
それも慈しみの言葉なんですね
で 朝顔に我々みんなを楽しませてくれと
それも自分だけ楽しむのではなくて
みんな楽しませてくれということだから
そういうふうに 何を見ても
生命に対するこの慈しみのメッセージを持つようにいっぱい俳句を書いてください
そうすると 普通に俳句書いちゃったらただの欲だけですから
地獄に落ちるだけですけど
結果としては こういう俳句書くと
書けば書くほど自分が徳を積んで
もう素晴らしい人間になるんです
そういう工夫をして この慈悲を身につくようにするんです
それはもう心を治すための特効薬で
病気治すために 精神的な病気の場合は
まあ他のとこ時探らなくちゃいけないんですね
それは瞑想をもって心の病気を治すこと
それからもう最後にもう一つなんですけど
皆様やっているこのサティの瞑想
慈悲のヴィパッサナー瞑想ですか
ヴィパッサナー瞑想は決して病気を治すために使ってはいけませんし
そう でもヨーロッパではもうなかなか心の病気を治すためにばっかり使ってるんですね
ヴィパッサナーのやり方は
心治す場合は やっぱり心の状態を見ただけで治るんですね
体の調子が悪い時でも
何のことなく ただ嫌でも思わないで
もう明るい気持ちで その痛みは痛み
痛みと観察すると 治して欲しい
その時は治して欲しいと思ってはいけない
そのまま病気であって欲しいとも思ってはいけない
えらい難しいんです 例えば足が痛いんだったら
それを治して欲しいと思うのはもうごく普通な感情なんですけど
例えば足が痛くて治して欲しくて
必死で痛み 痛み 痛みと思っても治らないんです
だからそこら辺難しいところ
そこを瞑想で乗り越えちゃえば
もう瞬時に治るんです
別に治して欲しくないでもないし
あって欲しくないでもなくて
ただ事実として 現実として
ありのままの姿として痛みを観察する
そうすると ヴィパッサナーを持っても結構早く病気は治ります
また 病気の治るお経はいくらかあるんです
お釈迦様は病気になったところで
お釈迦様はお経をあげてもらったんです
自分の弟子にお経をあげてもらったら
お釈迦様はすぐ病気が治ったんです
それはどういうお経かというと
やっぱりこの七覚支用の名前を念じるお経なんですね
七覚支っていうのは このヴィパッサナー瞑想で悟るために必要な七つの条件なんですね
一番目はサティ 二番目は託法なんとかっていう法分別意識ですね
法現象を分別して見られる力
それから精進 それから喜び
それ それから平安という落ち着き
それから統一サマーディ
それですね その七つを念じる
念じただけで病気が治るんですね
だから瞑想している人にとっては
その言葉を聞いただけでも
ものすごいエネルギーが生まれてくるんです
心の中に ですから そのお経を聞いたところで
そのお釈迦様も終わったらもう病気は立ち直ったと
お釈迦様も目連尊者にもそのお経を教えてあげ
祝福してあげた そこでお経を聞いてすぐ立ち上がったんです
皆様はそんなに早く奇跡的に病気が治らないと思います
お経を私があげても なぜならば
それほど修行の経験がないと
二番目はお経の意味はわからない
それでもお経にはすごい力があって
私と心が波動が合わせちゃったら治るんです
あげる私と波動が合うんだったらすぐ治るんですけど
それから皆様には思っていらっしゃいますから
この宝経 宝経でも自分の節でいいんです
心清らかにして楽しく唱えてみてください
慈悲経もいいし 慈悲経だったら意味を感じながら唱えてほしいんですね
真ん中の部分でもいいんですね
そういうのを唱えると
結構心清らかになって
病気などは治るんです
とにかくそういう慈悲の瞑想と特効薬であって
他の瞑想法もいろいろありますけど
とにかく明るい心でいれば
我々は健康的に生きることができるということで
どうもありがとうございました